i woke up a few days you know after
after the after the incident you know
and um
i was super emotional you know i was
super emotional
um
obviously frustrated um
these things have been just happening so
it's
like for us to just ignore that was
was was an issue for me and i feel like
me me me calling the nfl out me putting
that that pressure on on the league and
doing that using my platform
was it wasn't just you know to apply
pressure to them to you know it was to
apply pressure for people around me you
know to apply the pressure to myself you
know we all need to understand these
issues that are going on in our country
we all need to not only educate
ourselves further on these issues
we need to get out and vote you know
what i mean we need to get out and vote
and be a part of the electoral process
of these
of these policies you know um
this was this this was all
for me to you know apply the pressure
you know i
i didn't you know it was all positive
intentions you know obviously
i made a decision but i i stand by that
decision and i'm and i'm and i'm so and
i wouldn't have done it honestly if the
vikings didn't have my back and
and we had not already been talking
about these issues previously and
already had a council that was diverted
to these these specific issues and
that's and that's the reason why i
really feel like i had to step up
because you know in order for me to do
my part i need to start using my
platform and more of a more of a life to
musicians
[Music]
vikings linebacker eric kendricks from
earlier in the week he was the first one
shireen
to stand up and say of the nfl's initial
statement in response to the murder of
george floyd your statement doesn't say
anything it's not nearly enough what are
you going to do and i think that
contributed to the ground swell that
culminated in the nfl employee going
rogue and creating along with michael
thomas that video that kendricks was a
part of that patrick mahomes was a part
of and it really went a long way toward
getting something much more meaningful
out of the nfl now we'll see where it
goes from here the vikings doing
something meaningful a lengthy
conference call the other day you were
part of that what were your big
takeaways from what the vikings are
doing collectively to address these
issues
mike it was awesome one of the few press
conferences in my career where they
start off with we're not talking about
anything football related and it was
terrific and i just listened and and
that's what we are being asked to do
as white people is listen and it was
awesome to hear some of the things that
those guys have gone through
in their lives not talking about
football again but in their lives and
and uh you know where they are and where
they stand and what they intend to do
moving forward and you know eric
kendricks was the i i think he's become
another sort of face of the nfl i don't
know how many people knew eric kendricks
before this and i think it was important
for a viking to be part of that video
and a viking to speak out and eric
kendricks was the first to call out
roger goodell and say hey you were wrong
that not that statement that you made
said nothing and and it caused the nfl
to react after they made the video uh
that the players made last week and so
uh it was just it was absolutely awesome
it was really long but but it was
awesome i do think having said all that
they left three questions unanswered how
are they going to handle the minneapolis
police department they did not address
that rick spillman was on the call
one of their ceos was on the call uh
they did not address colin kaepernick
wouldn't talk about that you know would
they sign him or not and and then the
third thing i i think they left unsaid
was the national anthem they wouldn't
talk about that uh and mike zimmer has
has
seemed to indicate a couple years ago
that he would be against players
kneeling for the national anthem so i do
think there are questions that were not
answered but they have taken some steps
they've made the 5 million donate 5
million donation they've made a
scholarship in george floyd's name
they've taken some of those steps
they're encouraging people to get out
and vote and registering
players on their team to go vote
yeah the vikings one of the few teams
that have had to my recollection no one
kneeling or otherwise protesting during
the national anthem in the three or four
years since that that first started and
the colin kaepernick angle applies to
minnesota in two different ways number
one joe lockhart the former nfl
spokesman came out a couple of weeks ago
and and said the vikings are the team
that should sign him right now and when
you look at it from a football
perspective
gary kubiak the offensive coordinator of
the vikings was the head coach in denver
in 2016 when the broncos were
contemplating trading for colin
kaepernick the only reason they didn't
was because kaepernick refused to reduce
his 12 million dollar fully guaranteed
salary at the time and uh he fits he
fits with the offense and all due
respect to sean mannion colin kaepernick
would be a better backup to kirk cousins
than sean mannion
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports